[Musique]
bonsoir martin mc colis merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france la
première ministre convient d'entendre un
qui dit vouloir organiser un référendum
en cas de victoire de son parti aux
élections locales de mai prochain ce
sont les vieux démons qu'il surgisse
pour la grande bretagne
des proches de la star
la première mini qu'elle avait perdu le
dernier référendum et depuis elle encore
encore qu'elle en veut en saucière pour
le moment beaucoup de sondages montrent
que l'indépendance a le vent en poupe
cathy salle experts de premier rang des
sondages à lui que cela n'a rien de
certain
on ne peut pas prendre cela comme preuve
que l'indépendance serait gagnante et
d'autre part à londres doit donné sa
permission afin qu'ils y ait un
référendum pour le moment pour hishon
seul le premier ministre britannique est
d'inonder le parti national écossais va
remporter les élections et va remporter
deux autres élections car il est clair
que c'est eux le parti numéro un projet
pour le moment les causes est divisé
l'un des problèmes majeurs
c'est la monnaie déclaré d'une écosse
indépendante et garderait la livre
sterling
mais cette livrée garantis par la banque
d'angleterre dans une école indépendante
la banque d'angleterre ne pourrait
soutenir garantir la livre et co 16 donc
la livre écossaise
sa valeur c'est la difficulté majeure à
laquelle est confrontée l'ecosse et pour
le moment il n'y a pas de solution vous
nous dit en substance que l'ecosse
n'auraient pas les moyens de son
indépendance
effectivement l'économie ne se porte pas
très bien et l'économie pétrolière car
il ya de larges réserves de pétrole à
aberdyn se porte bien mais les prix du
pétrole ont chuté et les prix ne
suffisent plus aujourd'hui à financer
l'échiquier écossais le financent
écossaise je me le problème et d'autre
part qu'aider mme bourette un centre
financier majeur et beaucoup de services
financiers des banques à edimbourg
pourrait quitter la ville ce revenir
vers londres vers l'angleterre à cause
d'une livre écossaise très basse donc
c'est un problème supplémentaire
du point de vue économique les
perspectives ne sont pas très brillantes
mais nicolas sturgess disent que les cas
ça a était indépendante dans le passé et
qu'elle peut donc indépendante à nouveau
avant le 18e siècle elle était
indépendante donc elle pourrait l'être à
nouveau
mais il n'est pas certain que les causes
ce soit de pense accepté comme état
indépendant
car par exemple la catalogne en espagne
pourrait demander l'indépendance et
ensuite à rejoindre l'union européenne
donc du point de vue européen il est
également possible que l'ecosse ne
soient pas acceptés comme nouveaux
membres européens
alors on l'a dit tout à l'heure en 2014
un référendum avait déjà été organisée
causé avaient voté à 55% pour rester au
royaume uni vous nous disiez tout à
l'heure que les sondages étaient un
petit peu inversée en ce moment sans
préjuger évidemment d'un résultat final
comment expliquez vous cette tendance
qu'ont les écossais aujourd'hui à
l'indépendance la première raison c'est
que britten sol le premier ministre
britannique qui est très impopulaire en
écosse on le rend responsable du fiasco
de lakovic 19 c'est le mot qu'ils
utilisent ils le mettent en cause sa
gestion de l'épidémie
toutes ces actions sont considérées en
écosse comme anti écossaise et beaucoup
d'échos c'est aujourd'hui disent nous
voulons partir à cause de boris johnson
l'autre question c'est les écossais qui
vivent en angleterre devrait-il avoir le
droit de voter parce que par exemple
lors d'un lord élections récentes en
moldavie les moldaves bien qu'ils
vivaient à l'étranger ont pu voter
mais du point de vue écossais du point
de vue de nicolas stade jeunes il serait
dangereux de leur permettre de voter car
une majorité d ecosse vivant en
angleterre préféré que le royaume uni
reste unie et donc il ne vaudrait sans
doute pas pour l'indépendance si le
référendum avait lieu demain et borie
jeunes sont bien sûr devrait l'accepter
alors je pense que le résultat serait
bien plus serrée qu'auparavant cependant
il est très probable qu'une petite
majorité ferait qu' il n'y aurait pas d'
indépendance vous dites contre boris
johnson les contrôles boris johnson et
sombre excite surtout lui c'est surtout
le break site qui fait certainement peur
à beaucoup d'échos c'est qu'ils ont
envie de rester peut-être dans l'union
européenne
tout à fait il considère le bric sitcom
un danger pour les cosses économiquement
et politiquement
l'ecosse a voté pour rester au sein de
l'union européenne et le royaume uni
dans son ensemble a voté pour le départ
l'ecosse souhaiterait rester au sein de
l'union européenne et donc tout accord
du bric site est considéré comme une
catastrophe économique pour les gosses
et les écossais souhaiterait une
compensation un dédommagement il
préférait qu'il y ait un nouveau vote au
niveau du royaume uni sur le président
un nouveau vote afin de voir si les gens
ont changé d'avis par rapport au dernier
référendum en 2016 il est possible que
la population souhaite maintenant
rejoindre le royaume uni mais je pense
rejoindre union européenne mais je pense
que les écossais se trompe car le nombre
de personnes au royaume uni qui votent
pour le maintien sein de l'union
européenne à mon sens a baissé mais les
causes bien sûr considère toujours cela
comme un désastre économique pour sa
propre économie
merci beaucoup martin mc cauley d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur arte france
pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir merci